اهلا بكم الى موجز لاهم الانباء افاد مصدر
طبي سوداني بسقوط قتلى وجرحى جراء قصف
استهدف فجر اليوم منطقه حي النهضه بضاحيه
الانقاذ جنوبيه الخرطوم وكانت غرفه طوارئ
جنوب الحزام الواقعه الجنوبيه الخرطوم
قالت في وقت سابق ان قصفا جويا اودى
بحياتي اربعه مدنيين فضلا عن اصابه اخرين
مساء امس
قال مالك عجار نائب رئيس مجلس السياده
السوداني في تصريحات للجزيره مباشر انه تم
الاتفاق بين الاطراف خلال قمه الايجاد في
جيبوتي على عقد لقاء بين رئيس مجلس
السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد قوات
الدعم السريع محمد حميتي خلال اسبوعين دون
تحديد مكان للقاء واضاف ان اللقاء سيناقشه
3 نقاط هي وقف اطلاق النار والمساعدات
الانسانيه والعمليه السياسيه
اعلنت السلطات الاوكرانيه مقتل ثلاثه
اشخاص وجرح اخرين في قصف صاروخي علم ميناء
اوديسا وقال المتحدث باسم الاداره
العسكريه في اوديسا ان الهجوم استهدف
مجمعا تجاريا ودمر مستودعاته وتسبب في
حرائق من جهتها افادت السلطات المواليه
لروسيا في نوفاكا بان قصفا اوكرانيا اسفر
عن اصابه شخص في المدينه وقطع الكهرباء عن
بولودوفوي
قال رئيس هو بيلاروسيا الكسندر لوكاشينكو
ان بلاده بدات استلام اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه
من روسيا وكان لوكاشينكو قال في وقت سابق
انه لن يتردد في استخدام السلاح النووي
اذا تعرضت بلاده لاي اعتداء
قال السفير روسيا لدى الولايات المتحده
انا تولي انتونوف ان حزمه المساعدات
العسكريه الامريكيه الجديده لاوكرانيا
تدفع واشنطن بصوره اكبر لعمق الصراعا ياتي
ذلك بعد ان اعلن وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
عن حزمه مساعدات امنيه جديده لاوكرانيا
بقيمه 325 مليون دولار تتضمن مزيدا من
الاسلحه والمعدات بهدف دعم القوات
الاوكرانيه
اعلن وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انتوني
بلينكن انه تحدث مع نظيره الصيني وكتب
بلينك على حسابه على تويتر انه اجرى
مكالمه مع وزير الخارجيه الصيني ناقش
خلالها الجهود الجاريه لابقاء قنوات
الاتصال مفتوحه وقضايا ثنائيه وعالميه
من جهتها قالت وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه في
بيان انغ اعرب لبلين عن اسفه للصعوبات
الجديده التي تعتري العلاقات الصينيه
الامريكيه وحمل واشنطن مسؤوليه ذلك
قتل جنديان يابانيا واصيب اخر بجروح خطيره
في اطلاق نار خلال تدريب لمتطوعين بمعسكر
للرمايه وسط اليابان وقالت وزاره الدفاع
اليابانيه ان احد المتطوعين فتح النار على
زملائه من سلاح رشاش قبل ان يتم اعتقاله
ختم المجلس شكرا لكم والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]